for an in-depth look we're joined by
Kathleen Kingsbury she is the deputy
editorial page editor at The New York
Times Katie good morning hi good morning
let's start with a Korean summit which
that The Times called a carefully
choreographed diplomatic dance is there
the potential for real progress here or
there just a lot of optics at work yeah
I think everyone wants to be cautiously
optimistic at this point you know we
know that the North Koreans especially
are great at theater and choreography
and that's what we saw on Friday but we
really do want to hold out hope of a
nuclear-free Korea and we want to see
peace in that region and so I think you
know there's still a lot of information
to come but right now it's good to
celebrate this this development so what
what was president Trump hoping would
come out of this in particular as his
summit with kim jeong-hoon approaches in
the coming weeks yeah I think the White
House is definitely seized this is a
victory I think that however the North
Koreans have spent a lot of time
developing this weapons program the idea
that they're going to give it up
wholesale right away is probably not
going to happen but I do think that this
sets the groundwork for the president to
go and meet with them and to make some
serious demands I won't talk about Rear
Admiral Ronnie Jackson who withdrew his
name as a nominee for Secretary of
Veterans Affairs how significant is
setback do you think that is for the
White House I think it's actually a
major setback I think that one of the
things have gotten lost and the
questions around dr. Jackson's conduct
is the question of why was he ever
appointed to this position nominated to
this position to begin with the reality
is is that he had no qualifications
beyond being in the military and being a
doctor he had no management experience
and he was going to be running one of
the largest healthcare systems in the
country overseeing the care of veterans
and so I think that
is part of a pattern a troubling pattern
that we see from this white house that
doesn't seem to vet its candidates it
puts forward four large jobs and that
seems to often not really consider the
job that they're appointing that person
to before naming them and you know I
think it's interesting that we still
don't know who the next nominee is going
to be to run the VA it's a hugely
important organization and at this point
it's had no leadership for several
months now let's move on to that house
Intel committees report and it's
released 250 pages the Democrats are not
happy about it
they release our own Minority Report
what can you tell us about really what
came out of this well you know I I don't
know that there were any huge major
developments that came from this the
report was heavily redacted in fact
that's something that the Republicans
criticized it for you know we've found
some small new details about the
behavior of Michael Flynn for instance
but otherwise I think even especially
given the redacted state of it it became
clear that this report hadn't asked very
tough questions about the president's
conduct and his associates conduct I
think that where it just reinforces a
couple of things one is that it
concluded that there had been rushing
meddling in the election I mean that's a
major question what are we going to do
to make sure that that doesn't happen in
2018 and 2020 and then it also just
reinforces the importance I know the
president disagrees but it really
reinforces the importance of having
special counsel Moeller doing his
investigation and you know looking into
these really important questions about
interference by the Russians in the
election kathleen Kingsbury of the New
York Times thanks Katie thank you thank
you